اعتقد ان تمت سخاء وكرم عالمي بشان
الاوضاع في سوريا وهذا امر مهم لانهم
شهدناه العام الماضي هو الكثير من
الاهتمام بالاوضاع في اوكرانيا واحيانا
ربما اهتمام اقل بشان الاستجابه الاوضاع
في سوريا وفقنيسان وافريقيا ومن المهم حشد
المجتمع الدولي في هذه الظروف حتى يتم
تجاهل احتياجات اشخاص هم فيها مصر الحاجه
اليه عندما تغيب وسائل الاعلام عنه وهذا
ما يحدث الان هو اننا نستطيع ان نسلط
الضوء على الحاجه للاستثمار في الحفاظ على
الانظمه المياه صالحه للشرب وشبكات
الكهرباء والقطاع الصحي في الحاله جيده
للملايين من السوريين وهذه فرصه
لاعاده توجيه هذا النداء وللقول ان هذا
عليه خلال السنوات الماضيه هناك حاجه
للمزيد لاننا نرى ان الكثير من الانظمه هي
على حافه الانهيار هذا على المستوى العام
يعني المنظور العام كيفيه انقاذ
السكان في سوريا المواطنين السوريين